[Música]
el consejo de estado de Perú pide que se
esclarezcan las muertes relacionadas con
las protestas e insta a terminar la
violencia por medio del diálogo junto al
poder judicial mostraron su apoyo a la
propuesta de la presidenta Dina boluarte
de adelantar elecciones
alerta de salud pública en Santiago de
Chile la capital del país amaneció bajo
una capa de humo producto de los
incendios forestales desatados tras una
ola de calor este jueves la ciudad
registró 36,7 grados centígrados la
tercera temperatura más alta en un ciclo
La promesa la pobreza menstrual afecta a
Venezuela se denomina así a la
imposibilidad de acceder a productos de
higiene para atender la menstruación en
las zonas Rurales del país las
situaciones particularmente grave ya que
las mujeres no tienen acceso regular a
agua potable para su higiene personal
Hola y bienvenidos a las noticias de
América en France 24 los saluda Andrés
mesa Muñoz iniciamos en Perú después de
una reunión de carácter urgente el
consejo de estado pidió que se
esclarezcan las muertes relacionadas con
las protestas que se desataron tras la
destitución del expresidente Pedro
Castillo e instó a terminar la violencia
por medio del diálogo junto al poder
judicial mostraron su apoyo a la
propuesta de la presidenta Dina boluarte
de adelantar elecciones luego de que el
congreso rechazara la reforma
constitucional con la que se buscaban
realizar los comicios en 2023
todos los hechos tienen que ser
esclarecidos no solamente las muertes de
estas personas sino también los cientos
de heridos que tenemos en el hospital y
que se refieren a efectivos de las
fuerzas policiales que han estado
precisamente tratando de mantener el
orden No hay ninguna absolutamente
ninguna justificación para que se
ejerciten estos actos de violencia como
lo dijo el señor presidente de la junta
Nacional de Justicia pueden haber y
subyacer justos reclamos Pero eso se
hace a través del diálogo por lo demás
Nosotros hemos respaldado a la
presidenta en la solicitud que ha
efectuado del adelanto de elecciones y
en esa línea Es que el congreso de la
República tiene esa responsabilidad
vamos a Santiago la capital de Chile que
se encuentra bajo una alerta de salud
pública por una nube de humo provocada
por los incendios forestales que han
consumido más de siete mil hectáreas la
ciudad ha registrado temperaturas récord
de en medio de una ola de calor que
azota al país el servicio de
meteorología dijo que el jueves se
reportó 3 grados Celsius la temperatura
más alta que se ha visto en la ciudad en
111 años los detalles con nuestra
corresponsal en Santiago Patricia Luna
la capital de Chile Santiago amanecía
este viernes cubierta por una densa nube
de color café procedente de los humos de
los incendios que a solas no solo a la
región metropolitana sino también a la
vecina región de Valparaíso además
existía un ambiente lleno de humo con
olor ha quemado en toda la capital
chilena que producía efectos en los ojos
y también en la garganta las autoridades
se pasaban toda la jornada dando
recomendaciones a la población
especialmente a los adultos mayores a
las embarazadas y a los niños de
protegerse de este humo cerrar puertas y
ventanas no realizar actividades físicas
al aire libre y salir a la calle con
mascarilla el Ministerio de Educación
decidía suspender las actividades
físicas en los Colegios aunque mantenía
las clases y muchas comunas de la región
metropolitana suspendían todas las
actividades al aire libre el acceso a
las piscinas y las fiestas navideñas
entre otros eso en una jornada en la que
la oficina Nacional de emergencias
declaro que existía un total de 85
fuegos en todo el país 19 de ellos se
controlaron
Nada de este viernes el presidente
Gabriel boric cambiaba su agenda para
sobrevolar quilpué una de las zonas más
afectadas por el fuego en este momento
en la región de Valparaíso al menos uno
de los voluntarios combatiendo el
incendio Ha fallecido y otros se
encuentra herido por la el combate con
esta temporada de incendios que se prevé
mucho más activa que la de años pasados
la pobreza menstrual es una problemática
que afecta a gran parte de las mujeres
en América Latina y consiste en la
imposibilidad de acceder a productos de
higiene para atender la menstruación en
el caso de Venezuela donde el tema es
desatendido la situación se agrava en
las zonas Rurales donde las mujeres ni
siquiera tienen acceso regular a agua
potable para su higiene personal Daniela
Zambrano con el informe
Hernández vive en esta zona rural del
Estado Miranda tiene 26 años y cuatro
hijos es una de las decenas de mujeres
afectadas en el sector por la denominada
pobreza menstrual la inflación que
persiste en Venezuela le impide acceder
a toallas sanitarias y productos de
higiene durante el ciclo menstrual no sé
cómo voy a hacer ahorita cuando vengan
la menstruación
porque a veces me tengo que poner trapo
a veces a veces se me irrito y me tengo
que estar lavando con Montes caseros
como dice la gente
katiuska no tiene acceso regular al agua
potable en su comunidad en el mejor de
los casos el agua llega Por tubería cada
15 o 20 días a veces no reciben el
servicio durante meses lo que complica
aún más su higiene personal
por aquí pomposo yo a veces tuvo que vas
a buscar agua por allá abajo que si para
lavar y si para cocinar para bañar a los
niños en la misma población las hermanas
misioneras de Turbo y la ong acción por
Venezuela suministran kits para la
higiene menstrual de madres de niños que
alimentan en un comedor social Ana una
de las beneficiarias cuenta que en este
sector las mujeres tampoco tienen como
adquirir los medicamentos para aliviar
los dolores menstruales con la cuestión
de las pastillas hay que salir una hora
y media a comprarlas en otra parte
porque por acá no las venden según el
más reciente informe auspiciado por el
instituto de prensa y sociedad la
pobreza menstrual en Venezuela aumentó
en 40% se trata de una realidad
silenciosa que activistas de
organizaciones no gubernamentales como
Janeth Moreno intentan visibilizar para
llamar la atención de las autoridades
Consideró que hacen falta políticas
públicas Considero que falta educación
Considero que se tiene que atender
porque la higiene menstrual es sumamente
importante porque evita enfermedades
mientras que en Venezuela la pobreza
menstrual sigue siendo un tema sin
atención en países como Colombia en
México se han adelantado políticas
públicas para abordar el problema como
exonerar de impuesto al valor agregado a
los tampones toallas sanitarias y copas
menstruales a manera de facilitar a
mujeres y niñas el acceso a estos
productos de primera necesidad
nuevos problemas para Twitter y su nuevo
dueño elon musk la comunidad
internacional condenó la suspensión de
las cuentas de varios periodistas del
New York Times CNN y el Washington post
que según la red social habrían violado
la nueva política de privacidad por
compartir información del paradero en
tiempo real de su Jet privado la ONU
dijo que se trataba de una suspensión
arbitraria la comisión europea amenazó
con sanciones contra Twitter y
reporteros Sin fronteras calificó la
situación como un desastre el manejo de
la red social por parte de elon musk
quien se proclama como un defensor de la
libertad de expresión
autodenominado como absolutista de la
libertad de expresión en los modos
prometió reforzar la Libertad en el
flujo de la información a través de
Twitter cuando compró la plataforma pero
recientemente suspendió las cuentas de
media docena de periodistas Sin dar
ninguna explicación
Moss recurrió a Twitter luego de la
suspensiones para acusar a los
periodistas de compartir información
privada acerca de su paradero que
describió como básicamente coordenadas
de asesinato como es el caso de la
cuenta elonjet que había acumulado más
de medio millón de Seguidores y se
dedicaba a rastrear el uso de los
aviones privados del Magnate
estadounidense Desatando la ira de Moss
durante mucho tiempo
hace un mes el multimillonario de la
tecnología Se comprometió a permitir que
siguiera funcionando aunque fuera un
riesgo directo para su seguridad
personal según los informes el
estudiante universitario detrás de la
cuenta Jack sweeney había rechazado su
oferta de 5 mil dólares para eliminarla
Por otra parte la cuenta de mandon que
ha surgido como una alternativa Twitter
desde la toma de control de musk también
fue suspendida sin explicación el
comisionado de valores y transparencia
de la Unión Europea tuiteó que la
suspensión arbitraria de periodistas era
preocupante y recordamos el respeto a la
libertad de prensa y los derechos
fundamentales
mosc ha realizado cambios importantes en
la moderación de contenido en Twitter
desde que tomó control y ha restablecido
cuentas de alto perfil como la de Donald
Trump quien previamente rompió las
reglas de Twitter contra conductas de
odio o desinformación pero también ha
dicho que suprimiría la negatividad y el
odio al privar algunas cuentas de la
libertad de alcance
en Estados Unidos una corte de
apelaciones rechazó el intento de varios
estados republicanos de extender el
llamado título 42 se trata de una medida
implementada en marzo de 2020 y que
niega el derecho a los migrantes a
solicitar asilo para evitar que personas
contagiadas con Kobe 19 ingresen al país
los republicanos buscaban evitar que
esta medida expire el 21 de diciembre
como está previsto a medida que se
acerca a la fecha límite miles de
migrantes se han instalado cerca de la
frontera del lado mexicano
en sus primeras declaraciones oficiales
tras haber sido liberada la
basquetbolista estadounidense Britney
mencionó que reanudará su carrera y que
además abogará por los estadounidenses
detenidos en el extranjero Así lo dejó
claro a través de una publicación en su
cuenta de Instagram la estrella del
baloncesto salió este viernes de una
unidad médica militar en Texas donde
permanecía desde hace semana o una
semana tras haber llegado al país
procedente de Rusia
hasta aquí este Informativo en 24
Gracias por acompañarnos continúen con
toda nuestra programación
[Música]